hi guys and welcome back to roller
coaster kun three today's episode won't
be so much about actually building
buildings but much more about getting
some smaller things in between set
buildings and working on path elements
some flat rides and some ways to sort of
connect this part of the area to what is
going to be the future mountain as I
always feel buildings are just one part
of an area but without the actual path
works to connect it or and without some
way to transition between parts it's not
gonna actually end up looking coherent
and good and one of the things in which
i really want to put a lot of efforts in
this area is to actually make it all
come together and flow nicely as vague
and probably weird and spiritual as that
sounds out of my mouth right now I hope
it should make a little bit more sense
as this episode sort of progresses the
first thing that I wanted to get in here
with a flat ride it is definitely not
going to be this barrel flat right over
here I will eventually replace it where
they sort of enterprise ish right I did
complain about the lack of CFR's which I
did in last episode but probably also
prior to that quite many times and there
were a bit of like a few of comments who
said well yeah there are plenty of CFR
is out there that you can use that even
though they are fair ground CFR's you
might be able to use them for your park
but I really feel like it's with many of
them it's quite hard to actually use
them since they come with their own
fairground platforms and all of these
types of logos and things like that
which you don't really see in a theme
park and you can't exactly theme a
generic sort of ride that you would see
in the fairground as easily into a
certain theme and so I'm still sort of
struggling with that but for the
upcoming themes i do have a fair list of
flat rides which i want to use which for
this area are going to be that little
Enterprise is right on this plate on
this space and i also want to get a
barren sort of NORAD I've machine but
the Baron I don't know what it's called
exactly it's a it's an airplane thing
that should make sense eventually in
episode 121 even though it's not
finished yet it's in the planning so
you'll see that coming up
pretty soon the idea behind this ride
was to sort of keep it in between the
river and the path as to avoid this
entire platter from becoming too large
since as much as I wanted to leave a bit
of space over here open that so that you
would enter Germany have a bit of
breathing room maybe a restaurant to
your rights and a small plaza with a
nice atmosphere I didn't want to quite
make it to open and why I always find is
that if you have a very large Plaza
which is connected to water and there's
nothing really between it it really
quickly starts becoming this very vast
large area which I don't want to make
areas become to a vast like that and too
prone to agoraphobia that I really feel
like I wanted to put something in
between this Plaza and the river which I
figured a flat ride would be the best
thing since obviously since is this is a
theme park I want to throw it with quite
a bit of flat rides as well and then on
the other side of this flat ride the
other side of the tower that is I wanna
have the queue which isn't going to do
too much but it will provide a nice
little sort of in-between splits
transition between the path and the
river and there will be a bit of a like
riverside promenade with benches and
planters and lamps and all that good
stuff both on the Tyrolean Austrian side
of the tower as well as further down
this river on the German side but I
figured at this space since there was
this large plaza I really wanted to fill
it up with this right in the middle what
it also allowed me to do and this is
something that I probably should mention
too is to add different heights of was
different types of walls different
textures maybe some rock work in the
future and all sorts of details along
the side of this river since if there's
anything that makes my head itch it's
seeing a one big promenade beside a
river with the same war alongside the
entire river that goes in the same
direction it's I usually find that
really looks best if you sort of go the
more chaotic way and go with many
different shapes curves and different
types of textures and Wars alongside
especially a small River to make sure
that it all looks a little bit less
repetitive and predicted predictable and
that's really why I found a queue over
here would be perfect I wanted to cover
up this little space over here which
additionally helped to make this entire
area look a little less open and make it
feel more atmospheric and more it's hard
to put it I'm not the best and
adjectives but I I hope you get the
overall idea it's really to get that
more small time that small-town feeling
to this entire area but I want it again
AQ like that besides it's Germany and
the property rains a lot so you're gonna
have some sort of Q realistically some
sort of roof over it to at least keep
people dry so yeah that's the idea this
is sort of the parts of the queue where
you have a roof over it and the queue
sort of goes back and forth as you often
see and from that it's sort of just
moves straight to the flat right because
this is a small flat right off throw and
flat rides like this shouldn't have long
queues realistically because that's just
a hurdle to make your way through since
nobody really rides these things anyway
besides me of course usually another
thing that I should probably mention
just as a small tip in line with what I
said about using different textures and
shapes if you're adding these walls
alongside any sort of cliff face or
river is that along with that it is
usually best to really mix up the fence
types that you use even within an area
try to use as many fence types and wall
types and things like that as you can
just to make sure that it or sort of
doesn't look as repetitive of course you
should keep it within one theme so in
this case I really wanted to keep it to
wooden type fences but there's quite a
variety of different fences from Brian
chair and station Jim within this area
and even when it comes to small things
like colors it can even make a large
difference what you choose for this
fence for instance
I decided to actually go with the green
posts over though which is a very
strange choice given that it's just a
wooden fence but I really felt like I
wanted to do it given how already all of
the textures of the paths the walls and
the borders that I have over here are
very Brown ish and really wanted to get
a bit more color in aside from that and
given the very rustic colors that i have
in this area already really felt like
green was the best choice for me over
there now this building over here that I
sort of just quickly planned and then
quickly skipped over it is going to be
the restaurants eventually I'll come
back edit at the end of this video but I
won't quite finish it yet and it won't
be finished very soon but that is where
I plan to at least la restaurants to
fill up that plaza and make it feel a
little bit more atmospheric and
welcoming as you enter the German area
and over here is where i am adding the
flag pole for germany one thing to
notice about this flag pole is that it
will actually likely be moved to a
different location which has everything
to do with a number of requests or
requesting the same thing which i got in
the last video and it is about aim a
tree or i'm actually not going to
pronounce the dutch the german name that
is gonna just be awkward but yeah that
was a thing which multiple people from
germany requested and i felt sort of bad
about it as i read those comments since
i was happily planning to place the
Matri i was planning to place i'm a tree
but i was happily planning to do place
it in austria and not quite in germany
so to at least make it up for those
Germans I decided then i doona place i'm
a tree somewhere in this area but i
already recorded this specific episode
before I uploaded the last one so I
couldn't quite feature yet but i will
probably eventually in the future move
that flagpole turn it into a Matri make
it a bit fancy and attach a German flag
to Dimitri somewhere else in this area
so our at least feature that there was
also a request to actually have one of
these like three bail terms which is I
can't pronounce but is like these very
onion
shaped towers which you often see on
churches in not just Germany but also
Austria and many Orthodox churches and
Eastern Europe have them as well and to
be very honest about that I'll have to
say I don't really have much room in
this German area anymore to actually
make a building with such a tower on it
and I think given the fact that I gave
them a tree to Germany I think it's only
fair to give the table turn to Austria
and at least sort of balance things out
of that way if you can call it that so
yeah that's something to keep in mind
also you can probably see very small
black bars at the bottom and the top of
the screen don't worry about that I was
an idiot when rendering this time lapse
and I like messed some things up in the
crossing and then the cropping should be
too big of an issue but just so you know
that I'm also running out of classical
music so that's something that I will
have to go back at in the very near
future as well to make sure actually
keep my classical game music strong too
and this building over here is just the
very last of this facade I wanted to
make sure since I would have another
small plaza in front of this building
which I'm building right now that I got
some sort of building which you can
which not only sort of fits into that
facade and the sort of overall theme
that I have in that facade of the house
is pointing to them pointed toward the
river with our roofs like that but also
wanted to have a building which sort of
has an entrance fancy facade pointing
towards the future plaza on the other
side and so I've really figured that a
corner building like this with a fancy
spire on the corner would perhaps be the
best also safest option to go about
doing this so that's really about the
idea for this it's um you can almost say
it is a bit inspired by the breweries
the breweries I can't pronounce some
words that you often see in German
cities because they're all about the
beer and in front of this in that
fashion I also have some of those
typical do
like oktoberfests style picnic tables
lined up like the longer picnic tables
where you all sit together and eat
sausages and drink beer as Germans would
so that's the idea that I sort of have
behind this plant over here there will
also be another small flat right and
there will also be the may tree in that
small Plaza and then on the other side
of the plaza I plan to sort of have the
station of the roller coaster the mine
train that I'll have in this area as a
major weenie but that's or something for
next episode but this is just a still a
quite simple building something that I
should probably still say and this
applies to all of the buildings and for
quite a while too is that I'm really
just getting the basics of the buildings
down so I'm really just keeping it to
the architecture of the buildings
themselves so far I'm not quite getting
into actually making these facades look
alive which I feel is almost half of the
work but just by adding those little
plants little signs of life or literally
and figuratively signs of life and lamp
posts stuff like that is something that
I still need to get to and I really feel
makes buildings look a lot better in the
end but it's something that I will
procrastinate until a much further time
in the future since I really wanted to
make sure that before I had it into the
smallest and intricate details of this
area I really wanted to make sure that
any composition of the buildings is
something that I can stand behind so
yeah that's that and also here's another
this is the building which should become
the restaurants at some point in the
future and have a small little more nice
area with some tables and stuff like
that outside anyway that is just about
it for this episode a little on the
short side next one will be longer but
thank you guys for watching and I'll see
you guys later and I I suppose this time
it's most well it is most fitting to
actually sign off without Vida zein